مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مزز قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان حكومته لا تنوي
اقامه مستوطنه جديده رغم الغاء بنود من
قانون فك الارتباط لكنه وصف الغاء الكنيست
بنودا في القانون بانه شكل تصحيحا لقانون
تمييزي حضر على اليهود العيش في بيوتهم
حسب تعبيره
وكانت نائبه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
وانتشارما اعربت للسفير الاسرائيلي عن قلق
واشنط من قرار الكنيست الذي وصفته
بالاستفزازي واوضحت ان من شان الخطوه
الاسرائيليه ان تدفع الى مزيد من التوتر
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه مساء امس
الاربعاء ان بلديه القدس اقرت خطه لبناء
جديد جنوب القدس واضافت ان موقع الحي سيضم
11 سكنيه وان جزءا منه سيقطع التواصل
القدس الجغرافي مع بيت لحم
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان قرار
وشط مواصلتها تحقيق مسيراتها فوق البحر
الاسود يدفع روسيا لاتخاذ اجراءات مواجهه
محذرا واشنطن من اختبار صبري موسكو
وكان المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
العميد باتريدر اعلن ان القوات الامريكيه
تواصل عمليتها فوق البحر الاسود والتحليقه
في الاجواء الدوليه بما يراعي القانون
الدولي
في غضون ذلك قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان بلاده تستعد لمواجهه نوعين من التحديات
اولهما مباشر من منافسها الاستراتيجيين
كروسيا والصين والثاني بعيد الامد كتغير
المناخي والهجره والطاقه والامن الغذائي
والجوائح
اما وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
فقال ان بلاده ستكون مضطره للرد على
مواصفه بالتصعيد البريطاني بما يتماشى مع
العقيده النوويه الروسيه
اعلنت سلطاته دونيتسك المواليه لروسيا ان
القوات الروسيه طوقت بخموت بشكل شبهي كامل
وانها باتت تسيطر على سبعين في المئه من
المدينه من جهه قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
رئيس الاوكراني الذي زار المواقع المتقدمه
للجيش الاوكراني في منطقه بخموت
نقل موقع اكسسوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
قولهم ان اسرائيل ابلغت واشنطن ودولا
غربيه انها قد توجه ضربه عسكريه لايران
اذا خصبت اليورانيوم فوق مستوى مستوى 60%
واضاف ان اسرائيل طالبت من اوستن الاسراع
في تسليم 4 ناقلات جويه من طراز 46
لتزود بالوقود الجويه استعدادا لضربه
عسكريه محتمله في ايران
قال كبير مفوضين الايرانيين علي باقر انه
التقى بنظرائه في فرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا في اوسلو واكد بان
طهران مصممه على الدفاع عن مصالحها
الوطنيه بما في ذلك عبر المسار الدبلوماسي
مشاهدي
[موسيقى]